legalization of recreational marijuana
is a very public issue but consumption
of legal pot in the states where it's
allowed is mostly done in private
California's law is typical it says it's
illegal to consume smoke eat or vape
cannabis in public or even to open a
package containing it but the Golden
State now has a brand new venue led by a
cordon bleu chef where people can
partake in pot outside their homes the
nation's very first cannabis cafe is
open for business in the City of West
Hollywood take a look around it's really
and you might see something a little
different you could finally spoke in
public and smell it - I think this is a
big step in the right direction touristy
stigmatizing Queen welcome to the Lowell
Cafe America's first marijuana
restaurant where they serve traditional
comfort food with a side order of pot in
all its forms I get my own buzz but chef
Andrea drummer insists the food is not
infused with cannabis what would you
pair each of these items with you have
the burger the nachos the chef's salad
the chicken sandwich I would pair this
particular sandwich with our vape pen
because it does have citrus notes and it
goes well with that slaw then we also
have a super og cush that I would pair
with under the nachos or the burger a
tasting menu featuring pot might seem
odd considering you're an anti-drug
counselor
I was how does an anti-drug counselor
and a chef yeah yeah you know it's
really about being open-minded and
allowing your views to shift often we
get stuck in our perceptions about
things perceptions she hopes to erase
we're saying that it's time there's a
normalcy about cannabis
sumption that we've had to hide for some
time that it's no different than going
to a bar or going to a restaurant and
ordering a bottle of Merlot Drummer
teamed up with organic cannabis supplier
Lowell herb company together they Lobby
the City of West Hollywood to license
businesses that allow marijuana
consumption would you say the West
Hollywood has rolled out the welcome mat
for businesses like this 100% John
Leonard works for the city our council
didn't want to have a lottery or a
first-come first-serve they wanted to be
merit-based approach the Lowell Cafe is
the first of 16 spots that will allow
smoking and vaping or edibles businesses
that could draw tourists and pop up to 7
million tax dollars into the city how do
you make sure that people aren't getting
behind the wheel you know the way we're
doing it is the businesses are really
kind of in control when you first sit
down they ask what your level of
experience is with smoking cannabis or
ingesting canvas and they kind of walk
you through that process based on your
tolerance and your level and if you're
intoxicated they're going to certainly
help you get an uber or lyft ride home
it's similar to any bar here in this
city but instead of bartenders there are
flower hosts to help match tastes to
totes
the flavor profile is very distinct you
have strains that have a chocolate
flavor some are more pungent than others
some are very light what Heather
Birdwell and her girlfriends didn't
expect of course that opinion may have
come after the munchies set in vegans
and non-vegans alike really love this
the question is is this good the true
test might better come from someone
unexposed hmm wow that's really good
it's just a beautiful like community
that comes here and that's what I love
about it design team mark and Johnny
Houston the brains behind a dozen la
nightclubs and bars had to fuse function
with their vision
take the air filtration system which by
code had to keep aromas from floating on
to city streets to me when I looked at
it I thought was a bunch of Korean
barbecue hoods and I was like no I go I
have to redesign this to look a little
bit more approachable and not heavy and
then all the growth of like the
landscaping and everything that's going
to come over and take over it's
definitely not dark and dingy it's
welcoming it's I think surprising many
you're not hiding yeah we're not hiding
we're out here and embracing everyone
and letting them all know hey this is
your home to that sense of community was
another attraction for the city which
like the Lowell cafe's promise to pay
employees generously and give
opportunities to people who may have
drug offenses recreational marijuana is
legal in 11 states in Washington DC and
is expected to net more than forty
billion dollars by 2025
despite the drugs growing acceptance
nearly half of all drug possession
arrests in 2015 were for marijuana
there's a lot of people that went to
prison for having a menu like this
that's one point comedian Justin
Williams and his friend Brittany Chapman
hope won't get lost here I feel like
with this becoming natural in this area
it'll make it more common for us to
discuss the issues that have come from
cannabis in the past and if we discuss
those issues we can rectify those issues
and the two roots is going to be like
your beer and the needs will be like so
does you want cannabis legalized
globally and there's no concern that you
have for that widespread consumption
people right now drinking drinking
whiskey absolutely not is this a vision
of the future I think so I mean the
future is now we're living the
possibilities and we hope to see other
experiences that support cannabis
consumption they throw it at me so I
know you haven't been saved
but did you get a contact you know what
I did not I hate the smell of marijuana
I really do and those air filtration
systems that they had they really work
they're casino grade they purify the air
and it is part of the code you cannot
let that they had a police officer on
this other side of that wall and they
smelled it they could write a violation
and you guys be you guys talked about
this - I mean there's also the issue of
people smoking the marijuana then and
then eating and then yeah actually
driving right drives in LA same issue
with with with having a bar you know and
people drinking a lot to think about
very interesting Michelle thank you